Dieses Mal zur Eröffnungssitzung
des 50.
Weltwirtschaftsforums in Davos ist es ein Horror,
Sie zu empfangen, Herr.  Präsident zu diesem ganz besonderen
Anlass und Sie haben hier im Raum
und in einigen überfüllten Häusern
wirklich das Beste, was die Signal-Business-
Community zu bieten hat, zusätzlich zu über
300 Vertretern von Regierungen
kehren Sie in Begleitung einer starken
Delegation von Kabinettssekretären nach Davos zurück  und
hochrangiger Beamter ist ein Beweis dafür,
dass Sie die Notwendigkeit erkennen, dass
Amerika in den letzten zwei Jahren eine herausragende Rolle auf
der globalen Bühne behalten muss.
Die Geschichte der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung und Dynamik der
Aktienmärkte in den vergangenen zwei Jahren ist ein
Indiz dafür  Ebenso wie die rekordtiefe
Arbeitslosenquote zeigen die Anleger
großes Vertrauen in das kurz- und
langfristige Potenzial der US-Wirtschaft.
Präsident mit Neuigkeiten von Cisco, wir alle wissen, dass
die Vereinigten
Staaten und der Rest der Welt weiterhin vor Herausforderungen stehen
Vereinigte Staaten
[Applaus]
Vielen Dank, Klaus, und ganz
besondere Glückwünsche zu Ihrem 50.
Jahr als Gastgeber des Jahrestreffens des
Weltwirtschaftsforums. Eine wirklich erstaunliche
Leistung. Es ist mir eine Ehre,
zum zweiten Mal als
Präsident vor den angesehenen Mitgliedern dieser Organisation zu sprechen  Ich habe vor zwei Jahren auf diesem Forum gesprochen und
Ihnen gesagt, dass wir
heute das große amerikanische Comeback eingeleitet haben. Ich bin stolz, erklären zu können, dass sich die
Vereinigten Staaten mitten in einem
Wirtschaftsboom befinden, wie ihn die
Welt noch nie zuvor gesehen hat.  Wir sind wieder in
Schwung gekommen, haben unseren
Geist entdeckt und die mächtige
Maschinerie des amerikanischen Unternehmertums wieder zum Leben erweckt. Amerika
gedeiht, Amerika gedeiht, und
ja, Amerika gewinnt wieder wie nie
zuvor. Allein letzte Woche haben die Vereinigten
Staaten zwei außergewöhnliche Handelsabkommen abgeschlossen,
das Abkommen mit China und den
Vereinigten Staaten  Mexiko-Kanada-Abkommen
Die beiden größten Handelsabkommen aller Zeiten wurden
zufällig in derselben
Woche abgeschlossen. Diese Abkommen stellen ein neues
Handelsmodell für Abkommen des 21. Jahrhunderts dar,
die auf fairer Gegenseitigkeit basieren und
die Bedürfnisse von Arbeitnehmern und Familien in den Vordergrund stellen, die
Amerikas wirtschaftliche Wende mit sich gebracht
hat  Es war geradezu spektakulär,
als ich vor drei Jahren mein Amt antrat. Die
amerikanische Wirtschaft befand sich
unter der vorherigen Regierung in einem ziemlich düsteren Zustand. Fast
200.000 Arbeitsplätze im verarbeitenden Gewerbe waren
verschwunden. Die Löhne blieben gleich oder gingen zurück.
Fast 5 Millionen mehr Amerikaner hatten
die Erwerbsbevölkerung verlassen, als eine neue Arbeit gefunden hatten
mehr als 10 Millionen Menschen wurden
in die Liste der Lebensmittelmarken aufgenommen, die
Experten prognostizierten ein Jahrzehnt mit sehr, sehr
langsamem Wachstum oder vielleicht sogar negativem
Wachstum, hoher Arbeitslosigkeit und einer schwindenden
Erwerbsbevölkerung
und einer stark schrumpfenden Mittelschicht,
Millionen hart arbeitender
Normalbürger fühlten sich vernachlässigt  verraten und
vergessen, dass sie
vor Beginn meiner Präsidentschaft schnell das Vertrauen in das System verloren hatten.
Die Aussichten für viele Nationen waren düster.
Spitzenökonomen warnten vor einer anhaltenden
weltweiten Rezession. Die Weltbank
senkte ihre Prognosen für das globale
Wachstum auf einen Wert, an den niemand
auch nur an Pessimismus denken wollte
tief in den Köpfen führender
Denker, Wirtschaftsführer und politischer
Entscheidungsträger verwurzelt, doch trotz aller Zyniker war ich
noch nie so zuversichtlich in die
Zukunft Amerikas. Ich wusste, dass wir am
Rande eines tiefgreifenden wirtschaftlichen Aufschwungs standen,
wenn wir die Dinge richtig machten, die etwas
bewirken würden  Eine historische Welle von Investitionen,
Lohnwachstum und der Schaffung von Arbeitsplätzen. Ich wusste,
wenn wir das Potenzial unserer
Bevölkerung freisetzen, indem wir die Steuern senken und die
Vorschriften drastisch kürzen, und das tun wir in einer kurzen Zeitspanne auf einem Niveau,
das in der Geschichte unseres Landes noch nie zuvor erreicht wurde
Zeit, gebrochene Handelsabkommen zu reparieren und die
amerikanische Energie voll auszuschöpfen, dass der Wohlstand
mit Rekordgeschwindigkeit zurückkommen würde,
und genau das haben wir getan,
und genau das ist seit
meiner Wahl passiert. Amerika hat über
sieben Millionen Arbeitsplätze geschaffen, eine Zahl, die
ich mir nicht vorstellen kann  Sag es, ich würde nicht darüber reden,
aber das war eine Zahl, die ich im
Kopf hatte. Die Prognose lag bei zwei Millionen. Wir haben
sieben gemacht, mehr als das Dreifache der
eigenen Prognosen der Regierung. Die
Arbeitslosenquote liegt jetzt unter drei
Komma fünf Prozent und bei drei Prozent
Fünf Prozent, das ist die
niedrigste Zahl seit mehr als 50 Jahren. Die durchschnittliche
Arbeitslosenquote meiner Regierung
ist die niedrigste aller US-Präsidenten in der
Geschichte.
Wir haben
zum ersten Mal seit Jahrzehnten mit einer einigermaßen hohen Quote begonnen. Wir
konzentrieren uns nicht mehr nur  Reichtum in
den Händen einiger weniger Wir konzentrieren uns
und schaffen die umfassendste Wirtschaft, die es
je gab. Wir erhöhen die
Arbeitslosenquote von Amerikanern aller Rassen, Farben, Religionen und Glaubensbekenntnisse unter
Afroamerikanern. Hispanoamerikaner und
asiatische Amerikaner haben alle
Rekordtiefs bei der afroamerikanischen Jugend erreicht  Die Arbeitslosigkeit
hat den niedrigsten Stand aller Zeiten in
der Geschichte unseres Landes erreicht. Die
afroamerikanische Armut ist auf den
niedrigsten Stand aller Zeiten gesunken. Die
Arbeitslosenquote der Frauen hat den
niedrigsten Stand seit 1953 erreicht, und erstmals
stellen Frauen die Mehrheit der amerikanischen
Arbeitskräfte  Während die
Arbeitslosenquote für Veteranen
auf ein Rekordtief gesunken ist,
hat die Arbeitslosenquote für behinderte Amerikaner ein
Rekordtief aller Zeiten erreicht. Arbeiter ohne
High-School-Abschluss haben die
niedrigste Arbeitslosenquote in der
Geschichte der USA erreicht. Die Löhne steigen auf breiter
Front
und so weiter  Am unteren Ende der
Einkommensleiter erfreuen sich die prozentual bei
weitem größten Zuwächse. Die Löhne der Arbeitnehmer
wachsen jetzt schneller als die Löhne der Führungskräfte. Das
Einkommenswachstum der unteren 10 %
übersteigt das der obersten 10 %, was noch
nicht geschehen ist. Die Gehälter der
Abiturienten steigen schneller  Neben
Hochschulabsolventen haben auch junge Amerikaner, die gerade ins
Berufsleben eintreten, Anteil am
außergewöhnlichen Wohlstand Amerikas,
seit ich mein Amt angetreten habe. Mehr als zwei Millionen
Millennials haben einen Job gefunden und ihre
Löhne sind jedes Jahr um fast fünf Prozent gestiegen,
eine Zahl, die undenkbar war, dass
niemand jemals gedacht hätte  Das war
vor drei Jahren möglich.
In den acht Jahren vor meinem Amtsantritt sind heute eine Rekordzahl an Amerikanern im Alter zwischen 25 und 34 Jahren erwerbstätig.
In nur drei Jahren meiner
Amtszeit haben über 300.000 Menschen im erwerbsfähigen Alter die Arbeitswelt verlassen. 3,5 Millionen Menschen sind in
die Arbeitswelt eingetreten  10 Millionen Menschen
wurden in weniger
als drei Jahren aus der Sozialhilfe entlassen. Die Würde
der Arbeit zu feiern, ist ein Grundpfeiler unserer
Agenda. Das ist ein Arbeiterboom. Seit
meiner Wahl ist das Nettovermögen der unteren
Hälfte der Lohnempfänger um
plus 47 gestiegen  Prozent dreimal schneller als
der Anstieg des obersten Prozents. Das
reale mittlere Haushaltseinkommen ist auf dem
höchsten jemals verzeichneten Niveau. Der amerikanische
Traum ist zurück, größer, besser und stärker
als je zuvor.
Niemand profitiert mehr als
Amerikas Mittelschicht. Wir haben
1,2 Millionen produzierende Unternehmen geschaffen  und
die Zahl der Arbeitsplätze im Baugewerbe ist ebenfalls
undenkbar,
nachdem unter den beiden vorherigen Regierungen 60.000 Fabriken verloren gegangen sind.
Kaum zu
glauben, wenn man 60.000 Fabriken hört.
Amerika hat jetzt in sehr kurzer
Zeit 12.000 neue Fabriken
unter meiner Regierung hinzugewonnen, und die Zahl
wird rasant steigen, wird überragend sein  Die
Zahl von 60.000, die wir außer diesen verloren haben,
wird in jüngerer Zeit größer sein, und die letzten
Jahre der wirtschaftlichen Stagnation sind
einem tosenden Geysir der Chancen gewichen.  Die
Aktienmärkte sind
seit meiner Wahl um mehr als 50 Prozent gestiegen, haben das Vermögen der Haushalte um
mehr als 19 Billionen Dollar erhöht
und die 401.000-
Renten und College-Sparkonten
von Millionen hart arbeitender Familien aufgestockt, und
diese großen Zahlen sind viele Dinge,
und das trotz der Tatsache, dass die Fed dies
getan hat  Wir haben die Zinsen zu schnell angehoben und
sie zu langsam gesenkt, und selbst jetzt, da die
Vereinigten Staaten bei weitem die stärkste
Wirtschaftsmacht der Welt sind, ist es nicht
einmal annähernd klar, wer annähernd so weit sein wird, aber es ist
uns viel Gutes passiert und
einiges weniger Gutes  An
manchen Orten sind sie
zum Wettbewerb gezwungen, und wir konkurrieren mit Ländern,
die Negativzinsen erhalten. Das ist
etwas ganz Neues, das heißt, sie werden dafür bezahlt, sich
Geld zu leihen, etwas, an das ich mich
sehr schnell gewöhnen könnte, und das, was man
weiß, ist, dass man seinen Kredit zurückzahlen muss  Wie viel
ich bekomme, trotzdem haben wir immer noch
die besten Zahlen, die wir in so
vielen verschiedenen Bereichen hatten. Es ist ein konservativer
Ansatz und wir haben ein enormes
Aufwärtspotenzial, wenn alle Handelsabkommen
und die massive Deregulierung in
Kraft treten, was währenddessen der Fall sein wird  In diesem
Jahr, insbesondere gegen Ende des
Jahres, beginnen die Handelsabkommen bereits in Kraft zu
treten, und die Vorschriften treten bereits
jetzt in Kraft, und ich sehe ein
enormes Potenzial für die Zukunft, mit dem wir noch
nicht einmal begonnen haben, weil die
Zahlen darauf schließen ließen, dass wir viel
Zeit dafür haben  Die Skepsis hat ein Ende. Menschen
strömen zurück in unser Land.
Unternehmen kehren in unser
Land zurück. Viele von Ihnen, die ich kenne,
kommen mit Ihren Werken und
Fabriken zurück. Vielen Dank. Amerikas
neu gewonnener Wohlstand ist unbestreitbar
beispiellos und einzigartig auf
der ganzen Welt. Amerika  Wir haben diese erstaunliche
Kehrtwende nicht durch geringfügige Änderungen
an einigen wenigen Richtlinien erreicht, sondern durch die Annahme
eines völlig neuen Ansatzes, der sich ausschließlich
auf das Wohlergehen der amerikanischen Arbeitnehmer konzentriert.
Jede Entscheidung, die wir in den Bereichen Steuern, Handel,
Regulierung, Energie, Einwanderung, Bildung
und mehr treffen, konzentriert sich auf die Verbesserung der
Wir sind
entschlossen, den höchsten
Lebensstandard zu schaffen, den sich jeder vorstellen kann,
und im Moment tun wir das
für
den höchsten Lebensstandard der Welt, und wir sind
entschlossen sicherzustellen, dass die Arbeiterklasse
und die Mittelschicht davon profitieren  Der größte
Gewinn ist die höchste Pflicht einer Nation gegenüber ihren
eigenen Bürgern. Diese Wahrheit zu würdigen, ist der
einzige Weg, Vertrauen
in das Marktsystem aufzubauen. Nur wenn die
Regierungen ihre eigenen Bürger an die erste Stelle setzen,
werden die Menschen
in den Vereinigten Staaten voll und ganz in ihre nationale Zukunft investiert.  Wir
bauen eine Wirtschaft auf, die für alle funktioniert, und
stellen die Bande der Liebe und Loyalität wieder her, die
Bürger und Mächte
heute verbinden. Ich halte das amerikanische Modell als
Beispiel für die Welt für ein funktionierendes System
des freien Unternehmertums, das
den meisten Nutzen bringt  Menschen im
21. Jahrhundert und darüber hinaus. Eine Pro-Arbeiter-Pro-
Bürger-Pro-Familien-Agenda zeigt,
wie eine Nation gedeihen kann, wenn ihre
Gemeinden, ihre Unternehmen, ihre Regierung
und ihre Bevölkerung
im Rahmen dieser
neuen Vision, die wir verabschiedet haben, zum Wohle der gesamten Nation zusammenarbeiten  Mit dem größten Paket
von Steuersenkungen und Reformen in der amerikanischen
Geschichte verdoppeln wir die Steuergutschrift für Kinder, die
40 Millionen amerikanischen Familien zugutekommt
und 650.000 alleinerziehende Mütter und
ihre 1 Million Kinder
schnell aus der Armut befreit.
Wir haben die erste Steuergutschrift überhaupt für
Arbeitgeber verabschiedet, die solche Leistungen erbringen  Bezahlter
Vaterschaftsurlaub für Mitarbeiter, die 72.000
Dollar oder weniger pro Jahr verdienen, und bezahlter
Familienurlaub für Regierungsangestellte als
Modell für das Land. Wir haben die
Kinderbetreuung viel erschwinglicher gemacht und die
Wartelisten für die Kinderbetreuung
im ganzen Land reduziert oder abgeschafft. Unsere
Reformen der Kinderbetreuung unterstützen berufstätige
Eltern  Um sicherzustellen, dass ihre Kinder
Zugang zu qualitativ hochwertiger Betreuung und
Bildung haben, die sie alle sehr
verdienen, haben wir unsere Gewerbesteuer von
der höchsten in der entwickelten Welt
auf eine Steuer gesenkt, die nicht nur wettbewerbsfähig ist,
sondern auch eine der niedrigeren Steuern ist, die wir
fast neuntausend geschaffen haben  Chancenzonen
und notleidende Gemeinden, in denen
Kapitalgewinne aus langfristigen Investitionen jetzt
mit Null besteuert werden und enormer Reichtum
in Gebiete strömt, in denen
die 35 Millionen Amerikaner, die
in diesen Gebieten leben, in 400 Jahren oder nichts bereits erlebt haben, wie der
Wert ihrer Häuser um mehr als
zweiundzwanzig gestiegen ist  Milliarden Dollar, meine
Regierung hat auch historische
Investitionen in historisch schwarze
Colleges und Universitäten getätigt.
Ich habe HBC-Nutzung gespart
Außerdem haben wir die ehrgeizigste
Kampagne in der Geschichte gestartet, um
arbeitsplatzvernichtende Vorschriften zu reduzieren. Mit jeder neuen
Verordnung, die wir erlassen, streichen wir acht
alte Vorschriften, wodurch ein
durchschnittlicher amerikanischer Haushalt etwa
3.100 US-Dollar pro Jahr einsparen wird  Wir
konnten
diese Hilfe aufheben, und wir glauben, dass sie
noch ein ganzes Stück höher ausfallen wird. Wir
haben heute noch einen weiten Weg vor uns. Ich fordere andere
Nationen auf, unserem Beispiel zu folgen und
Ihre Bürger von der erdrückenden
Last der Bürokratie zu befreien, die Sie
übernehmen müssen
Wir stellen auch die verfassungsmäßige
Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Amerika wieder her, die
für unsere Wirtschaft, unsere Freiheit und
unsere Zukunft von wesentlicher Bedeutung ist. Aus diesem Grund haben wir
über 190 Bundesrichter ernannt, die eine
Rekordzahl von 190 Bundesrichtern haben, um das Gesetz so auszulegen, wie es geschrieben steht
Richter des Obersten Gerichtshofs sind der Meinung, dass aufgrund unserer
Bemühungen
im ersten Halbjahr 2019 Investitionen in unser Land strömten. Die
Vereinigten Staaten haben fast
ein Viertel aller ausländischen Direktinvestitionen angezogen,
und auf der Welt sind es 25 %
Alle ausländischen Investitionen auf der ganzen
Welt kamen in die Vereinigten Staaten und
diese Zahl nimmt rapide zu.
Jedes Unternehmen sucht einen Ort, an dem es
frei investieren, gedeihen,
innovieren und erfolgreich sein kann. Es gibt keinen besseren
Ort auf der Welt als die Vereinigten Staaten
als Zentrum  Im Rahmen unseres Engagements für den
Aufbau einer integrativen Gesellschaft haben wir
den National Council for the
American Worker gegründet. Wir möchten, dass jeder Bürger,
unabhängig von Alter oder Herkunft, über
die neuesten Fähigkeiten verfügt, um
am Arbeitsplatz von morgen konkurrenzfähig und erfolgreich zu sein. Dazu
gehören wichtige Branchen wie
künstliche Intelligenz und
Quantencomputing  und 5G unter Ivankas
Führung, die heute bei uns ist,
ist unser Versprechen an Amerikas Arbeiter zu einer
umfassenden nationalen Bewegung geworden, mit über
400 Unternehmen, die sich dazu verpflichten,
bereits fast 15 Millionen
amerikanischen Studenten und Arbeitern neue Arbeits- und Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten zu bieten. 15 Millionen
macht Amerika  Umfassende Änderungen, um
Arbeitnehmer und ihre Familien in den
Mittelpunkt unserer nationalen Agenda zu rücken.
Die vielleicht transformativste Änderung von allen betrifft die
Handelsreform, bei der wir uns mit
chronischen Problemen befassen, die
jahrzehntelang ignoriert, toleriert oder ermöglicht wurden. Unsere
Führer haben nichts dagegen unternommen
Bevor ich gewählt wurde, haben wir uns mit dem Handel beschäftigt.
Chinas räuberische Praktiken haben den
Handel für alle untergraben, aber
niemand hat etwas dagegen getan, außer zuzulassen, dass
es
unter meiner Führung immer schlimmer und schlimmer wurde. Amerika hat sich
dem Problem im Rahmen unserer
neuen Phase-1-Abkommensphase direkt gestellt  2
beginnt in Kürze mit den Verhandlungen.
China hat zugestimmt, im Wesentlichen Dinge zu tun,
die es nicht getan hätte,
Maßnahmen zum Schutz des geistigen
Eigentums zu ergreifen, erzwungene Technologietransfers zu stoppen,
Handelshemmnisse zu beseitigen und
landwirtschaftliche
Kulturgüter sowie landwirtschaftliche Güter,
bei denen wir so schlecht behandelt wurden, seinen
Finanzsektor vollständig zu öffnen  Das ist geschafft und wir
sorgen für eine stabile Währung, gestützt durch
sehr, sehr strenge Durchsetzungsmaßnahmen. Die
Beziehungen zu China waren im Moment
wahrscheinlich nie besser. Wir haben
eine sehr schwierige Phase durchgemacht, aber es
war noch nie besser. Meine Beziehung
zu Präsident Xi ist außergewöhnlich,
er ist für China  Bis zu den USA, aber
ansonsten lieben wir uns
außerdem. China wird
in den nächsten zwei Jahren weitere 200 Milliarden Dollar für amerikanische Dienstleistungen in den Bereichen
Landwirtschaft, Energie und
Industriegüter ausgeben, sodass wir mehr als
200 Milliarden US-Dollar einnehmen könnten  300
Milliarden US-Dollar, wenn es zu Ende ist, aber diese
Erfolge wären
ohne die Einführung von
Zöllen, die wir anwenden mussten, nicht möglich gewesen, und wir
wenden sie auch auf andere an, und deshalb
werden die meisten unserer Zölle gegen China
während der zweiten Phase in Kraft bleiben  Die
Verhandlungen haben die Zölle zum größten Teil
aufgegeben und es wurden
Milliarden und Abermilliarden Dollar pro
Jahr gezahlt, da ein Land, wie ich bereits erwähnte,
die NAFTA-Katastrophe beendete, eines der
schlimmsten Handelsabkommen, das jemals abgeschlossen wurde, noch
nicht einmal abgeschlossen hatte, und es durch das
Unglaubliche ersetzte  Neues Handelsabkommen der USA  MCA, also
Mexiko und Kanada, verloren in den fast
25 Jahren nach dem NAFTA-Abkommen in den Vereinigten Staaten
jeden vierten Arbeitsplatz im verarbeitenden Gewerbe,
darunter fast jeden vierten Arbeitsplatz im Fahrzeugbau
Durch das
Abkommen wurde der Reichtum in die Hände einiger
weniger verlagert, das massive Outsourcing gefördert, die
Löhne gesenkt und
Betriebe und Fabriken zu Tausenden geschlossen  Das
Produkt anderer Länder, das
nicht mehr vorkommt, ist das
Wrack, für dessen Beseitigung ich gewählt wurde.
Es ist wahrscheinlich mehr als alles andere der Grund, warum ich für das Präsidentenamt kandidiert habe,
weil ich nicht verstehen konnte, warum wir
all diese Arbeitsplätze an andere
Länder verlieren  Das ging so schnell voran, und es
wurde immer schlimmer, und ich denke, das ist
wahrscheinlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich kandidierte,
aber es gibt auch andere Gründe, als es
durch ein neues System zu ersetzen, das die
Arbeitnehmer über die Sonderinteressen stellt, und
die Sonderinteressen werden völlig ausreichen
Aber die Arbeiter stehen an erster Stelle. Nun, das
brandneue US-amerikanische MCA ist das Ergebnis der breitesten
Koalition, die jemals für ein Handelsabkommen zusammengestellt wurde.
Industrie, Landwirtschaft und
Arbeitnehmer haben das Abkommen alle nachdrücklich befürwortet, und
wie Sie wissen, wurde es gerade mit überwältigender Mehrheit im Kongress angenommen und
zeigt, wie die
Herausforderung des 21. Jahrhunderts gelöst werden kann  Wir alle stehen vor
dem Schutz geistigen Eigentums, der
Ausweitung des digitalen Handels, der Sicherung verlorener
Arbeitsplätze und der Sicherstellung steigender Löhne und
Lebensstandards. Die Vereinigten Staaten haben
außerdem ein großartiges neues Handelsabkommen
mit Japan über etwa 40 Milliarden
Dollar abgeschlossen und unser
Abkommen mit Südkorea, über das wir ebenfalls
verhandeln, komplett neu ausgehandelt  Viele andere Transaktionen mit
vielen anderen Ländern und wir freuen uns
auf die Verhandlungen über ein großartiges neues Abkommen
mit dem Vereinigten Königreich. Wir haben einen wunderbaren
neuen Premierminister, der einmal sehr darauf bedacht ist,
ein Abkommen abzuschließen, wie es heißt, um unsere
Sicherheit und unsere Wirtschaft zu schützen.
Wir begrüßen auch mutig die amerikanische Seite
Energieunabhängigkeit: Die Vereinigten Staaten sind
mittlerweile mit Abstand der größte
Erdöl- und Erdgasproduzent auf der ganzen
Welt, bei weitem nicht einmal annähernd, während
viele europäische Länder mit
lähmenden Energiekosten zu kämpfen haben. Die amerikanische
Energierevolution spart amerikanischen
Familien jedes Jahr 2.500 US-Dollar bei der Senkung
Stromrechnungen und Zahlen, von denen die Leute
sagten, dass sie nicht möglich seien,
und auch ganz wichtig die Preise an der
Zapfsäule. Wir waren so erfolgreich, dass die
Vereinigten Staaten keine
Energie mehr von feindlichen Nationen importieren müssen, die
jetzt im Überfluss an amerikanischem Erdgas
verfügbar sind, oder von europäischen Verbündeten  Wir müssen auch nicht länger
anfällig für unfreundliche
Energielieferanten sein. Wir fordern auch unsere
Freunde in Europa auf, Amerikas riesiges Angebot zu nutzen
und echte Energiesicherheit zu erreichen, wobei
wir Unternehmen und Forscher den Weg weisen.
Wir stehen an der Schwelle
praktisch unbegrenzter
Energiereserven, auch aus traditionellen Brennstoffen
LNG, saubere Kohle, Kernenergie der nächsten Generation
und Gashydrattechnologien
zugleich. Ich bin stolz, berichten zu können, dass die
Vereinigten Staaten zu den saubersten Luft-
und Trinkwasserqualitäten der Erde gehören, und wir
werden dies auch weiterhin tun, und das haben wir gerade
herausgebracht  Ein Bericht, der besagt, dass
es derzeit so sauber ist wie seit
40 Jahren nicht mehr. Wir engagieren uns heute für den
Erhalt der Majestät der Schöpfung Gottes
und der natürlichen Schönheit unserer Welt.
Ich freue mich, Ihnen mitteilen zu können, dass die
Vereinigten Staaten der Initiative „1 Billion Bäume“ beitreten werden
Hier auf dem
Weltwirtschaftsforum haben wir 1 Billion Bäume ins Leben gerufen,
und dabei werden wir weiterhin
starke Führungsstärke zeigen und das Wachstum
und die bessere Bewirtschaftung unserer Bäume und
Wälder wiederherstellen. Dies ist keine Zeit für Pessimismus,
dies ist eine Zeit für Optimismus, Angst und
Zweifel nicht  Ein guter Denkprozess,
denn dies ist eine Zeit enormer
Hoffnung und Freude, Optimismus und Handelns, aber
um die Möglichkeiten von morgen zu nutzen,
müssen wir die ewigen Untergangspropheten
und ihre Vorhersagen der
Apokalypse ablehnen.
Sie sind die Erben der
dummen Wahrsager von gestern und ich  Sie haben sie und
Sie haben sie und wir alle haben sie
und sie wollen, dass es uns schlecht geht, aber
das lassen wir nicht zu. Sie haben
in den 1960er Jahren eine Überbevölkerungskrise, in den 70er Jahren Massenhunger
und in den 1990er Jahren ein Ende des Öls vorhergesagt, diese
Alarmisten  Fordern Sie immer das Gleiche,
absolute Macht, um zu dominieren,
jeden Aspekt unseres Lebens zu verändern und zu kontrollieren. Wir
werden niemals zulassen, dass radikale Sozialisten
unsere Wirtschaft zerstören, unser Land ruinieren oder
unsere Freiheit ausrotten. Amerika wird
immer die stolze, starke und
unnachgiebige Bastion der Freiheit in Amerika sein.
Wir verstehen, was  Die Pessimisten
weigerten sich zu erkennen, dass eine wachsende und
dynamische, auf die Zukunft ausgerichtete Marktwirtschaft
den menschlichen Geist erhebt und die
Kreativität stark genug anregt, um
jede Herausforderung zu meistern, jede Herausforderung bei
weitem die großen wissenschaftlichen Durchbrüche
des 20. Jahrhunderts, von Penicillin über
Hochleistungsweizen bis hin zu modernen
Transport und bahnbrechende Impfstoffe
haben den Lebensstandard erhöht und
Milliarden von Leben auf der ganzen Welt gerettet, und
wir arbeiten weiterhin an Dingen, von denen
Sie in naher Zukunft hören werden,
dass Sie selbst heute, wenn Sie hier sitzen,
nicht glauben würden, dass es
möglich ist  dass wir die Antworten gefunden haben, die
Sie darüber hören werden, aber wir haben
Antworten auf Dinge gefunden, von denen die Leute sagten, sie
wären nicht möglich, schon gar nicht in
sehr kurzer Zeit, aber die
Wunder des letzten Jahrhunderts werden im
Vergleich zu denen von heute verblassen  Junge
Innovatoren werden etwas erreichen, weil sie
Dinge tun, die niemand jemals für
möglich gehalten hätte. Wir setzen weiterhin auf die
Technologie, um sie nicht zu scheuen, wenn die Menschen die
Freiheit haben, Innovationen zu schaffen. Millionen werden nun seit
drei Jahren ein längeres, glücklicheres und gesünderes Leben führen.
Amerika hat der Welt
den Weg gezeigt  Der Weg zu einer wohlhabenden Zukunft
beginnt damit, dass die Arbeitnehmer an erster Stelle stehen und sich für
Wachstum entscheiden, und
Unternehmern die Freiheit gegeben wird, ihre Träume zum
Leben zu erwecken. Für alle, die daran zweifeln, was
in der Zukunft möglich ist, brauchen wir nur einen Blick
auf die gewaltigen Errungenschaften der Vergangenheit zu werfen, die
nur ein paar hundert Meilen von hier entfernt sind, um nur
einige davon zu nennen  Von den großen Städten Europas
voller Handels- und Kulturzentren
ist jede von ihnen voller Erinnerungen daran,
was menschlicher Antrieb und Vorstellungskraft
vor Jahrhunderten, zur Zeit der
Renaissance, erreichen können. Erfahrene Handwerker und
Arbeiter blickten nach oben und bauten die
Strukturen, die noch immer das Menschliche berühren
Bis zum heutigen Tag wurden
in Italien vor Hunderten von Jahren einige der großartigsten Bauwerke der Welt errichtet. Die
Bürger begannen einst mit dem Bau eines
einhundertvierzig
Jahre dauernden Projekts,
des Doms von Florenz, eines unglaublichen,
unglaublichen Ortes, während die Technologie
noch nicht ausgereift war  existierten, um ihren
Entwurf zu vollenden. Die Stadtväter machten ohnehin Fortschritte und waren sich
sicher, dass sie es
eines Tages herausfinden würden. Diese Bürger von Florenz
akzeptierten keine Grenzen für ihre hohen
Ansprüche und so wurde
schließlich in Frankreich die große Kuppel gebaut. Ein weiteres
jahrhundertealtes Projekt stoppt diesen
Einfluss weiterhin  Es liegt uns im Herzen und in der Seele, dass
selbst 800 Jahre nach ihrem Bau
die
Kathedrale Notre Dom
letztes Jahr in Flammen aufging, ein so trauriger Anblick, ein
unglaublicher Anblick, vor allem für
diejenigen von uns, die sie als eines
der großartigsten Denkmäler betrachteten und
dies auch repräsentieren  Viele verschiedene Dinge, die
die ganze Welt durch ihr
Heiligtum betrauerte, stehen jetzt verbrannt und verkohlt da,
und ein Anblick, der kaum zu glauben ist, wenn
man sich daran gewöhnt hat,
ihn anzusehen. Jetzt ist es kaum zu glauben, aber wir
wissen, dass kein wahres DOM wiederhergestellt werden wird, sondern
großartig wiederhergestellt wird  Die großen
Glocken werden wieder für alle erklingen, um
Gott zu ehren und Millionen
mit Staunen zu erfüllen, und alle Kathedralen
Europas lehren uns, große Träume,
gewagte Abenteuer und ungezügelte
Ambitionen zu verfolgen. Sie drängen uns, nicht
nur darüber nachzudenken, was wir heute gebaut haben, sondern auch  Was wir noch
lange nach unserem Tod ertragen werden, sie
zeugen von der Macht gewöhnlicher Menschen,
außergewöhnliche Erfolge zu erzielen,
wenn sie durch ein großes und edles Ziel vereint sind.
Deshalb müssen wir gemeinsam mit
Zuversicht, Entschlossenheit und Vision voranschreiten. Wir
dürfen nicht schüchtern, sanftmütig oder ängstlich sein, sondern
Stattdessen müssen wir den Tag mutig nutzen und
den Moment umarmen, in dem wir so viele großartige
Führungskräfte in diesem Raum haben, nicht nur
Wirtschaftsführer, sondern auch Führungspersönlichkeiten von Nationen, und einige
leisten so fantastische Arbeit, dass wir
sehr eng zusammenarbeiten und
aus deren Ruhm Kraft schöpfen werden
Wir werden die Vergangenheit zu unserer gemeinsamen
Mission machen und gemeinsam für die Zukunft werden wir
unsere Nationen stärker machen, unser Land ist
sicherer, unsere Kultur reicher, unsere Menschen
freier und die Welt schöner als
je zuvor. Vor allem aber werden wir
für immer loyal sein,
unsere Arbeiter, unsere Bürger  und unsere
Familien, die Männer und Frauen, die das
Rückgrat unserer Volkswirtschaften, das Herz
unserer Gemeinschaften und die Seele unserer
Länder sind, lassen Sie uns einer nach dem anderen Licht in ihr
Leben bringen und sie befähigen,
die Welt zu erhellen.
Vielen Dank, Gott segne Sie  Gott
segne Ihre Länder und Gott segne
Amerika.
Danke, vielen Dank.
[Applaus]
Herr.  Präsident, ich danke Ihnen für Ihre Rede
und gratuliere Ihnen zu dem, was Sie
für Ihre Wirtschaft, aber auch für
Ihre Gesellschaft, die wir hier sehr
intensiv diskutieren, erreicht haben. Es ist eine Frage der
Inklusivität, aber Ihre gesamte Politik
zielt sicherlich darauf ab, eine bessere
Inklusivität für das amerikanische Volk zu schaffen, dem ich
danken möchte  Sie persönlich,
insbesondere dafür, dass Sie
unseren Diskussionen Optimismus verliehen haben, wir haben viele Probleme auf
der Welt, aber ich denke, wir brauchen, wie Sie
sagten, Träume und wir haben alle
Fähigkeiten, die Technologieführerschaft zu
verwirklichen, also Ströme, also nochmals vielen Dank,
Herr.  Präsident, dass er hier
bei der Eröffnung des 50. Jubiläums
der Weltwirtschaft für
[Applaus] dabei war.